hallo herzlich willkommen meine trocken
welt heute gibt es endlich wieder ein
süßes rezept von mir ich werde heute
fruchtarten herstellen das ist so eine
schokoladen schokoladen teig mit einer
frucht creme und einer pfefferminz
schokolade das ist eine sehr schöne
kombinationen ich finde geschmacklich
passte sehr gut zusammen und zuallererst
muss jetzt die garage gestellt werden
dafür zeige ich es einmal die zu
enthalten für die garage 450 gramm sahne
schlagsahne und ihr braucht after eight
und zartbitterschokolade ihr könnt doch
auch da ist eben auch diese günstigere
variante nehmen die gibt's glaube ich
bei lidl und aldi einfach wegen der
pfefferminze schokolade wird es gerne
mögt wir nicht neben dir einfach sag'
bitterschokolade update habe ich hier 80
gramm das sind 10 von diesen kleinen
teufelchen und 20 gramm peter kurer
ich werde jetzt aber nicht mehr zeigen
wie man die garage stellt dazu habe ich
schon viele viele videos gemacht ich
kann euch main kanal spiegel hier unten
auch als video antwort posten schaltet
einfach die sahne aufkochen
die schokolade reingeben einmal
vermissen und dann einfach in den
kühlschrank stellen ist was ihr später
eben brauchen also die garage muss
später richtig schön kalt sein und wählt
das dann erledigt habt könnt ihr den
teig vorbereitet und was sie dazu an
zutaten werde dies zeige ich euch führt
den rührteig braucht ihr zwei eier 100
gramm zucker 50 gramm 20 gramm stärke 20
gramm kakaopulver dann nehmt ihr peter
buck und kein kaaba eineinhalb teelöffel
backpulver 40 gramm öl und 50 gramm
mineralwasser wie immer werden zuerst
zweier verrührt werden rühren lasst ihr
den zucker einrieseln und lasst es
wichtig schon aufschlagen
die trockenen zu tragen
ihr könnt die auch gerne rein 7 oder
einfach so mit reinen geben
ich mache mal mein sieg grad in der
maschine ist da kommt auch direkt das
wasser mit rein und das öl und jetzt
wird es kurz eingerührt dann auch schon
datei kommt dann auf ein backblech oder
auf einfach horst meint ihr ist vom noma
streichen muss jetzt auch nicht komplett
ganze fläche ausfüllen und abdeckung und
so wird das nun bei 170 grad für etwa
zehn bis zwölf minuten gebacken ihr
müsst die stäbchen probe machen und
könnte dann aus dem ofen nehmen für sie
der tag dann aus den ziehe ich jetzt
einmal vom backhaus und lege ein etwas
feuchtes küchentuch darüber das ist
eigentlich austrocknet und wer möchte
kann jetzt noch etwas likör oder rum
darüber träufeln zb seine frucht likör
und wenn ich möchte lässt es einfach so
abkühlen werden die teigplatten auskühlt
kann ich schon mal den frucht spiegel
herstellen
den mache ich jetzt schon damit einfach
auch schon abkühlen kann und ihnen
später ebenfalls verwenden kann
ich benutze jetzt als früchte heim gp
von bern und johannisbeeren
ihr könnt aber alles nehmen was ihr
wollt im winter bietet sich zum beispiel
an dass ihr das orange nehmt ihr könnt
auch ganz gut wie keinen frischen beeren
hat könnte auch tiefgekühlte bären
nehmen oder diesen bären mix also alles
da habt und alles was schmeckt ist dann
auch wichtig ist eben nur dass er die
richtige menge benutzt und die
verrechnet für den frucht spiegel
braucht ihr etwas mehr als 100 gramm
früchte
ich habe jetzt 450 gramm johannisbeeren
30 heidelbeeren und 30 gramm bomben also
wie hier die früchte dann zusammenmischt
ist egal hauptsache ihr habt so etwas
mehr als 100 gramm
ich finde die konstellation aber ganz
gut weil die johannisbeeren recht sauer
sehen die bromberg die heidelberger süß
das passt also für mich optimal
ihr braucht 50 gramm saft ich habe jetzt
einfach so johannisbeer apfelsaft oder
während saft besser wäre natürlich ein
purer johannisbeersaft oder eben
heidelberg saft und spritzer zitrone
wenn ihr es gern etwas sauer mögt und
teelöffel zucker und einen teelöffel
speisestärke die zutaten gebt ihr dann
alle in einen kleinen topf den topf habe
ich jetzt schon mal angeschaltet auf die
höchste stufe
doch mittels fans groß dann wird das
ganze einmal durch püriert ihr könnt es
im prinzip auch im thermomix machen
uns reicht auch wenn es einen treffer
auf kopf
da könnte es vom herd nehmen und am
besten ihr macht gescheiter als ich
nimmt einen höheren topf oder püriert
die früchte vorher dann spritzt es nicht
so in der gegend rum und stammt passiert
ihr das ganze macht durch einen sieht
damit die ganzen kerne und stück hier
noch mehr kommen wir dann so eine schöne
samtige konsistenz bekommt
kleines gefäß um machen deckel drauf und
lass es einfach abkühlen
wenn der pegel dann vorbereitet ist
könnt ihr schon mal die creme herstellen
ich mache heute eine quarkcreme mit
joghurt und sahne und ich mache es
einfach so weil ich das ganz gerne mag
falls aber keinen joker hat oder keinen
joghurt mögt könnt ihr auch einfach nur
quark benutzen
ich finde es aber ganz wichtig dass ihr
quark benutzt unsere weil der quark
etwas fester ist und eben dann die masse
nicht so flüssig wird falls ihr aber
keinen fragte habt oder den nicht so
gerne mögt könnt ihr auch ganz gerne
frischkäse oder aus capone nehmen die
sind ja auch hinter konsistenz ziemlich
fest und brauchen eigentlich keine
zusätzlichen bindemittel damit sie fest
sind und wie gesagt verwende ich jetzt
quark und joghurt und zeigt euch jetzt
einmal welche menge benötigt für die
creme braucht ihr 100 milliliter sahne
ihr braucht zwei teelöffel sahen abfahrt
oder ihr nehmt euch einfach sahne fest
ihr braucht 50 gramm beeren die werden
gleich püriert ich habe jetzt einfach
wieder so eine bunte mischung gemacht
aus den drei früchten
ihr braucht 75 gramm joghurt ich habe
jetzt dieses mal sahnejoghurt genommen
zum griechischen hatte aber letztes mal
ein joghurt mit 35 prozent es hat super
geklappt da wird nur den genommen weil
da schon offenbar 125 gramm magerquark
40 gramm puderzucker und den saft und
die schale einer halben zitrone
zuerst werde ich jetzt die sahne mit
einem teelöffel salz steif schlagen
kühl stellen dann höre ich meine früchte
und damit ist jetzt nicht mehr so
spritzt mache ich das in meiner kleinen
küchen einem stabmixer und hierfür rühre
ich jetzt den quark mit dem joghurt mit
der zitronenschale dem puderzucker und
dem saft von einer halben zitrone und
stark kommt jetzt noch ein teelöffel
sein apartment rein
das berühre ich einmal ganz kurz
kommt gleich die früchte mit rein und
wer wieder keine kerne möchte kann die
vorher wieder durch dem sieb passieren
soweit ich das jetzt machen
etwas zu flüssig ist dann gebt ruhig
nochmal ein teelöffel sein apartment
rein dann wird da jetzt die sahne
untergehoben in den kühlschrank bis sich
die teigplatten vorbereitet habe jetzt
kommt es im weiteren schritt an was ihr
jetzt für geschirr benutzt ihr könnt so
stabile benutzen oder wie ich ich habe
hier von tuba bachhaus etwas ganz tolles
das sind so geschichten und stapel
das war so ein 3er set hat glaube ich so
um die zehn euro gekostet und da kann
man ganz gut eben sachen rein schichten
und später dann einfach raus stürzen mit
hilfe dieses abnehmbaren einsatz
und da passt jetzt ganz gut mein wasser
klares als ausstechen
das hat die richtige größe und da ich
sex so ringe habe brauche ich zwölf
kleine kreise weil es eben einmal decken
reinkommt und ein
ein boden
die werden dann da reingelegt bisschen
an gedrückt
für die decke lege ich mich zur seite
und stieß übrige teig wird jetzt
natürlich nicht weggeschmissen den
bewahre ich in einer kleinen box aus und
vielleicht später wenn auch etwas creme
garage übrigbleibt daraus keine trüffel
formen oder eben nutzt sie einfach um
die ganz normale trickboxx tour jetzt
nehmt euch einfach eure quark joghurt
creme und gebt dann jeweils ein
löffelrein schön darin verteilen
da dürfte wenn ihr die gleichen formen
habe nicht zu viel rein machen die haben
so eine bestimmte markierung hier
und die darf nicht übersteigen und dabei
gleich noch der deckel drauf kommt
müsste eben unter dieser markierung
bleiben dann nehme ich mir so einen
deckel weg den darauf jetzt könnte das
auch direkt aufeinander stapeln und es
hilft dann auch bei diesen formen dass
das eben schön platt gedrückt wird und
schön glatt wird die oberfläche
hier gebe ich jetzt im deckel drauf und
so kommt es jetzt bei mir in den
kühlschrank von der seite sieht es
übrigens so aus da könnten etwa die
struktur sehen
die teilchen dann fertig geschichte
tipps kommen sie in den kühlschrank dort
sollten sie mindestens eine stunde
leitungen besser ist es aber wenn jetzt
morgens zubereitet und mittags oder
abends eben verzerrt ihr könnt ihr aber
auch ganzen tag vorzubereiten könnte
einfach den kühlschrank stellen
und am nächsten tag daneben verlieren
vor dem servieren nehmt ihr euch jetzt
die gage stimmt jetzt erst mal
aufgeschlagen werden und viele haben
immer noch probleme mit der gar nicht so
fest ist es ist einfach so wenn ihr
weniger schokolade benutzt in
verhältnisse sahne dann ist es ja auch
noch relativ flüssig und dann müsst ihr
das erst noch steif schlagen im prinzip
nichts anderes als schokolade mit sahne
und das heißt wenn sie etwas flüssig ist
und er als creme benutzen wollt dann
müsst ihr es einfach steif schlagen und
so weit ich das jetzt machen die
kanarische ist jetzt ganz kalt und muss
jetzt einmal noch schnell aufgeschlagen
wird
ihr seht da wird sie dann auch heller
dann habe ich jetzt meinen spritzbeutel
über ein gefäß gestülpt und gäbe da die
garage frei
und hier habe ich so eine stern schüler
drauf und ihr zweiten die das
angerichtet ich werde einfach pro person
ein törtchen servieren und wie ich das
genau mache zeige ich euch jetzt
und jetzt mache ich das so dass ich die
dinge hier auseinandernehmen dahin
platzieren wo ich sie hinhaben möchte
und jetzt dekoriere ich erstmal diesen
frucht spiegel
ich mache keine frucht spiegel sondern
mache einfach so eine bahn hier aus
und da kann man dann später die
kuchenstücke schön rein punkten
die schälchen herab mach dich mit der
geräumt
könnte wenn ihr die törtchen ohne kamenz
der mädchen und etwas puderzucker drüber
schreiben
das wird ja auch schon reichen aber wie
gesagt wollte ich ja noch diesen kamins
geschmack mit drin haben deswegen gebe
ich da jetzt noch die garage obendrauf
und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr jetzt noch
so ein achteck nehmen das in der mitte
auseinander brechen oder schneiden und
das hier schön dekorieren und hier würde
ich jetzt noch so eine johannisbeer
darüber geben und das war's dann im
prinzip schon
und so sieht dann mein fertig ist dass
er aus mir schwebt die kombination aus -
schokolade und der früchten und dem
schokoladen boden sehr gut
ich hoffe dass euch das rezept genau so
gut gefällt hat er keine kleinen
teilchen machen wollt könnt ihr auch
ganz gut eine große torte damit machen
das heißt ihr müsst einfach die menge
nehmen und auf spring formen umrechnen
ich würde sagen dass die menge jetzt für
zwei biscuit böden mit dem durchmesser
24 cm reicht also halbiert euch einfach
dann den teig bugs zwei verschiedene
böden auf und dann können die creme
schön rein geben und wenn ihr möchtet
dann eben noch mit dieser schokolade
sahne garnelen
ich werde ich wünsche euch jetzt auf
jeden fall viel spaß mit dem rezept und
viel spaß beim backen
ich wollte euch noch sagen dass ich
nächste woche zur ifa fahre nach berlin
dass sich die internationale
funkausstellung und da bin ich jetzt das
erste mal mit dabei
ich wollte auch alleine hin reisen weil
man mankell zeit hat und die show wird
dann einfach mal an ich hab nämlich vom
letzten jahr so ein paar youtube videos
gesehen und hab da zum beispiel auch
trailer von der firma heiq ist das ist
küchen aus schotter und da bin ich auf
jeden fall sehr gespannt darauf was ihr
interesse habt dass ich dann mit meiner
kamera hingeht dann können wir gerne
bescheid sagen dann kann ich ja damals
vor ort filmen und euch zeigen was ist
das alles gibt aber vielleicht geht ja
auch der eine oder andere von euch
selbst dahin
dann können wir da vielleicht sehen und
auf jeden fall würde ich mich freuen
euch doch zu treffen und wie gesagt
falls ihr lust habt dass ich da
irgendwie ein kleines video drüber träge
oder mal euch zeigen wie es da aussieht
was es da für geräte gibt dann sagt mir
bescheid ich würde mich freuen und dann
sehen wir uns schon beim nächsten mal
wieder und